ce garçon a le poids d'un enfant de
trois ans mais salim avait 8 ans quand
une journaliste de la bbc a tourné ces
images en 2016 avant la guerre le garçon
marchait et jouer avec ses frères et
soeurs dit ce mot existe en 1 20 ce
garçon est affamé je crains que ce soit
le début d'une famine disait la pédiatre
yéménite
il y a deux ans les images du petit
salim avait provoqué une onde de choc le
monde apprenait alors que les
bombardements menés par l'arabie
saoudite était en train d'affamer des
millions d'enfants
mais le choc des images n'a rien changé
en 2016 350 mille enfants étaient en
état de malnutrition aiguë aujourd'hui
ils sont 5 million selon l'onu
les images terribles qu'on voit
aujourd'hui on les voyait en 2016 des
enfants arrivent dans des états de
malnutrition aiguë sévère absolument
atroce il ya beaucoup de souffrance donc
il ya des enfants qui meurent au yémen
la guerre a fait au moins dix mille
morts depuis trois ans la famille
n'aurait fait plus victimes que les
bandes
les petits affamés envahissent les
hôpitaux des villes elle même envahi par
des millions de déplacés
des gens qui ont fui leurs villages
bombardés nous sommes venus des
montagnes dit cet homme
mais il n'y a pas de travail pas de
sucre pas d'essence nous cuisinons avec
le bois à cause de la guerre 75% des
limites dépend désormais de l'aide
alimentaire pour vivre et l'aide peine à
se rendre en raison des bombes et du
bleu que s'imposer par l'arabie saoudite
depuis septembre nous ne pouvons
toujours pas accéder à 51 mille
cinquante mille tonnes de céréales dans
les silos de la mer rouge qui avait été
vous vous souvenez attaqué en septembre
si nous pouvions accéder à ces silos et
aux céréales de ses silos nous pourrions
aider 3 7 millions de personnes
supplémentaires pendant un mois wallet à
1 heure plus tard la journaliste de la
bbc est retourné dans le village de
salim
garçon a été sauvé par l'aide
alimentaire distribuée d'urgence dans la
région
mais sa famille me manque toujours
désespérément de nourriture sa mère dit
qu'elles ne mangent que du pain car elle
peut en trouver parfois le soleil se
couche dit elle et je n'ai pris que du
thé le petit salines qui a maintenant
dix ans gardera des séquelles toute sa
vie son cerveau a été atteint de façon
irrémédiable et ses jambes ou si il ne
pourra plus jamais marcher
sophie langlois radio canada montréal